bitten europas sind wir schweizerinnen
und schweizer insulaner
der deutsche lyriker friedrich hölderlin
sagte es einst zu was kümmert mich der
schiffbruch der welt ich weiß von nichts
als meiner seligen insel
200 jahre später schwimmt die schweiz im
europäischen länder mehr
eine insel viele labels wir gelten als
indie der glückseligen als
hochpreisinsel zuweilen gar als
pirateninsel oder auch als wehrpflicht
insel
franken
kassieren insel ja aber gut weil man
grenzen works in europa sicherer so als
insellage
er kennt sich aus mit den helvetischen
insulaner wolfgang heuer der deutsche
autor lebt in stäfa bei zürich jahrelang
schriebe als korrespondent für die
süddeutsche zeitung über die schweizer
gesellschaft und deren eigener für ihn
ist die schweiz nicht erst seit der
angenommenen masseneinwanderung
initiative eine insel es ging glaube ich
schon ganz am anfang an die klassische
entwicklung war dieses abgetrennte
territorium schwer zugänglich bäuerlich
gebirge skeptisch gegenüber außenseitern
es kamen immer leute die durch wollten
den hat man es war auch mit skepsis
begegnet aber man wusste die bringen
geld und das war die einzige wirkliche
einnahmequelle das heisst die schweiz
musste schon immer einerseits insel
andererseits aber auch zugang finden zu
den außenstehenden und das hat sich bis
heute fortgesetzt
pauli kann es mit der schweiz in seinem
bestseller die besser kölner analysierte
er liebevoll unsere nationalcharakter
auf sie sich brav sein wir und
selbstbewusst beschreiben man ist stolz
auf seine besonderheit aber man weiß man
kann nicht ohne die die von außen kommen
und das ist das dilemma an dem sich die
schweiz abarbeitet und was sich am
deutlichsten dokumentiert im verhältnis
zur europäischen union wer darf auf die
insel das stimmvolk entscheidet am 30
november über die initiative der
vereinigung umwelt und bevölkerung kürze
coup die zuwanderung soll fix auf 0,2
prozent der einwohner beschränkt werden
das wären jährlich rund 16.000 menschen
in den letzten jahren wanderten
durchschnittlich 63.000 menschen neu in
die schweiz ein und
eco pop will zehn prozent der schweizer
entwicklungsgelder also circa 140
millionen franken fix für die
familienplanung in armen ländern
ausgehen zu viele kinder in afrika seien
der hauptgrund für die dort in
entwicklungsdefizite die initianten
sprechen von jährlich 80 millionen
ungewollten geburten
in riesa bei genf genießt philipp rogg
sein rentnerleben im grünen
der ehemalige chef des bundesamtes für
umwelt fungiert als aushängeschild der
initiative er warnt vor einer
zubetonierten und überbevölkerten
schweiz
der umweltschützer distanziert sich von
rechten ideologien die auch zu rekord
bewegung gehören trotzdem kämpfte für
die verknüpfung von migrations und
umwelt politik es geht zusammen leider
muss ich sagen dass man bringt meine
periode die sicheren naturschutz aber
menschheit hat sie zu immer noch einmal
zusammen aber wenn wir nichts
unternehmen und dass immer mehr leute in
die schweiz kommen dann wird diese natur
kaputt die leute werden weniger gut
leben hier seien sie schweizer oder
ausländer dass die amerikaner das haben
wir das zusammen anstreben
die nationalrätin nadine masshardt
kämpft gegen die insel schweiz und gegen
kuba die initiative tue nichts gegen die
zersiedelung und den ressourcenverbrauch
gänzlich unverständlich für die junge
mutter die angedachte geburtenkontrolle
in entwicklungsländer mit usb stick
stellt ist a und o er entdeckte
zusammenarbeit und tatort rolle von frau
stechen und ich hab's durch muster für
europa das vielleicht wenig geschehen
geht aber es kann nicht sie das mega-
schweiz kommen und sagen der in afrika
müssten weniger ausläuft wenn die kind
gebar aber mehr die wir wie salat
standortqualität führen wir das annehmen
möchte das liegt doch sehr
kolonialistisch der welt ihren stempel
aufdrücken so der plan einiger insulaner
und dabei hoffen dass die welt nicht zu
ihnen kommt schon komisch und auch wenig
realistisch die schweiz wird immer
weniger wie eine insel aussehen die
schweiz ist eher wie eine hallig das
sind die inseln hüther nordsee oder auch
der messstelle ist eine hallig das heißt
wir sind nur eine insel wenn die flut
ist und wenn er bekommt dann kann man
diese inseln trockenen fußes erreichen
und so ähnlich ist es mit der schweiz
und die elbe perioden werden immer
länger werden und vielleicht eines tages
ganz verschwinden und dann ist diese
ehemalige inseln halt teil des festland
meisters also für die insel schweiz
schon bald land in sicht und nochmal auf
hölderlin zu kommen beim schiffbruch der
welt haben auch wir schweizer gerne
trockenen boden unter den füßen